here I am in security Command Center the
risk and Security Management platform
for Google cloud and I'm looking at the
graph from an attack pod simulation to
determine if any of my Cloud's resources
are vulnerable to attack and what bad
things could happen if they were now
before today I would have to investigate
this map node by node each has vital
info after all understand what the
findings mean and determine what to
proactively address and what steps I
would need to take but now with duet AI
in security Command Center it generates
a summary of what resources can actually
be exploited and how to remediate the
vulnerabilities these summaries enable
me to take quick action to improve our
security posture